[Music]
it up in the tall grass Sam hunt cuddles
up to fiancee Hanna Lee Fowler mid
performance at the ACM till we get there
every answers on five here's what Sam
told Edie just before the ACM started
that's a big changes for you oh my god
wait a minute stop you don't married no
not yet well you're just wearing an
engagement yeah I put it on to try it on
and decided it felt so good
and I didn't want to take it all there's
only a few weeks left before we do get
married so a few weeks yeah coming up
soon he tells the date uh no I can't
come on cuz I'm trying to keep it
low-key
and I'm sure nobody would show up but
they might what kind of nuptials do you
have planned is it gonna be intimate big
hometown destination uh intimate and
hometown with the two adjectives that
we're about correct they're low-key
low-maintenance we're both kind of
introverted people for the most part so
we don't we don't like celebrating
ourselves too much if there ever is the
time to do it it's now and it's more to
celebrate the union of marriage than it
is each other
and I'm just excited about doing that
Hannah with you tonight she is yeah this
your first red carpet together yes it
means you guys to be able to finally
step out together after everything
you've been through it means a lot
because this change in lifestyle happens
when the two of us weren't weren't
dating and together so I'm sort of been
introducing her to my new life a little
bit at a time over the last six months
and this is a big leap compared to some
of the small steps we've taken so far so
I hope she enjoys it it's a radical
change for sure but um she's optimistic
and I'm proud that she's out here with
me yeah
fun tonight already yeah so far she
looks gorgeous and and I'm she's feeling
good smiling so that's a good sign
how did you know that it was the right
time to propose um it's just that that
feeling you have that heart radar that
guides us in life it just starts tapping
on your shoulder when it's time and you
just make a move so that's what I did
[Music]